hi everybody welcome to 13 o'clock this
is our second episode and we have a
really really fun topic I'm so excited
about this Tom tell them what the topic
is the topic is the Satanic Han oh I
can't say tannic panic of the 1980s if
you didn't live through it you you don't
know you don't even know the half of it
they won't even believe it they won't
you guys will not believe this if you
know if you're a young person listening
to this and did not live through the
1980s like we did mmm you will not even
believe this is the thing but I assure
you it was it really did happen it was
the real thing and in it was the one of
the few times in history where you could
you could watch full-grown adults act
like total idiots well you can kind of
see them it was the time in which you
would walk down the streets and people
would throw things at you out of their
car yeah why you say accuse you of doing
bad things to children yeah yeah it was
awesome yeah it was a [ __ ] show it was a
once you lay it out yeah why don't you
tell us what the satanic panic was and
about when it started
okay well the satanic panic as it is
understood generally in the media really
didn't kind of kick in until the 80s but
I do think that the kind of seeds of it
the roots of it kind of 1960 were
probably late 60s and I think what I
think what was happening you know in the
late 60s there was the whole counter
cultural revolution the hippies
blah-dee-blah yeah and you know there
was this whole schism between the young
and the old New Age
yeah and New Age really no new age like
people were abandoning traditional
religion and you know so you got like
these people that were getting into
these like silly cults and things like
incest with weird cults most of them New
Age calls yeah and so then and then like
in the 70s it seemed like there was kind
of a lot of interest in cultic type
entertainment she had you know you had
movies like Rosemary's Baby and The
Exorcist
oh man Rosemary's Baby was late 60s
though yeah 68 that came and actually
the book came out in 66 I'm Ana's gotta
take it back to Han Anton LaVey
but I would say that was probably the
very beginning he was laying the
foundations for the satanic panic to
come yeah
now that Rosemary's Baby was kind of
happening at the same time they were
they kind of came up together yeah and
that was like the foundation that I
think the satanic panic was built on
yeah the concept that there were secret
satanic cults of people that you would
never you would never guess that they
were involved in it and they wanted your
baby or they want to get you pregnant
yeah and then they wanted you baby yeah
it was pretty much I think that was
pretty much the same general concept
throughout the entire satanic panic yeah
it's just that other things started to
get thrown into it
like music heavy metal music what else
serial killers got thrown into it yeah
dungeon the dragon dungeons a drag yeah
we'll talk about that okay but um so
yeah I think well I think what ended up
happening was that people that kind of
grew up in the 60s you know once they
got to the 80s when they were having
kids of their own maybe they were
remembering all this crazy [ __ ] they did
like back in the sixties like oh I was
in a cult or I was interested in
whatever so they I think they kind of
projected like onto the society at large
that there were these huge organized
groups of Satanists that were routinely
kidnapping children and sacrificing
people losing women as breeders using
women as brood mares and that cries they
could sacrifice the baby and eat the
baby and whatever ridiculous and like I
said I think a lot of it was protection
people were buying into it that was that
was the weirdest which is hard to
believe but it was actually a pretty
mainstream thing it's like pretty much
every daytime talk show at the time well
that was later that was 80 yeah that was
well that was late eighties yeah yeah it
didn't really
it kind of felt like it had fizzled out
like by the late 90s Marilyn Manson
happened but yeah probably after that
Marilyn man went mainstream Marilyn
Manson and Jerry Springer yeah together
killed a satanic panic yeah because when
Jerry Springer came out all of a sudden
you realize you were being trolled what
all these daytime talk shows they were
pretending to be serious they were today
yeah with a hold on all this time he's
these daytime talk shows were not
respectable oh my god never did me got
trolled yeah yeah and then then of
course Marilyn Manson came out who was
openly calling himself the Antichrist
Superstar and he was a likeable guy it's
kind of pulled the pole he was he knows
it's funny I thought you're funny you
know he wasn't yeah yeah he could answer
a question intelligently and he had a
little bit of charisma before he went
crazy yeah well and sorry cocaine's a
hell of a drug right so basically here
was the thing and like I said we're
probably more mostly going to talk about
the 80s because that was kind of the
heyday of it and that's what I remember
the best yeah now so it came about the
biggest things I think were kids that
were getting into heavy metal music you
know Slayer venom even like the older
ones like Iron Maiden them yeah they
went back to Judas Priest and they were
messing with actually ac/dc of all
things ac/dc and check this out what was
it the guys that did stairway to heaven
like that one that's that one yeah them
too
well we saw they had they had like
backwards masking yeah which wasn't
there no it wasn't and so yeah kids that
are into heavy metal kids that were
playing judging the Dragons right and
what was funny is that didn't happen all
at once it was one thing got piled on
after another yeah
to live through it to understand the
[ __ ] show that transpired It was as if a
cyclone of [ __ ] but was being sucked
into a black hole of [ __ ] imagine a
cyclone and a black hole made of human
feces happening at the same time that's
what it was like [ __ ] ception it was
like simpson's yeah religion was in
there heavy metal was in there it was
absolutely ridiculous and the shitty
thing too is that it seems like a lot of
you know cause like a lot of the you
know serial killers Son of Sam the
nightstalker Richard Ramirez they kind
of you know whereas before the satanic
panic happened yeah these guys would
have just been seen as like lone psychos
yeah which they weren't yeah but you
know in light of the satanic panic with
all these people thinking there was a
big organized network of these crazy
people yeah so they kind of got you know
they kind of got bombed on to that hold
that whole theme you know where oh they
were part of us some yes serial killers
and that started with Charles Mann yes
serial killers cult leaders rock music
and Anton LaVey all got mushed into one
thing
yeah and that and it was after your baby
was after your children yeah the
churches had all the parents just in a
total panic
it was literally a modern witch hunt
yeah that's exactly that's exactly what
it was and and law enforcement was
involved they went to prison over this
no allegations we're gonna get into that
yeah yeah and that's that's kind of the
[ __ ] I mean it's funny now well you know
it wasn't funny then but not so funny
that and not so funny for some of the
people that got that went to prison
allegations yeah and
let's kind of talk about what are we
going to talk about first you want to
talk about dungeons of Dragons first I
think Dungeons & Dragons is probably
when it first started to come into the
public eye right mass yeah get to it to
the kid it was it was a story about a
kid who came up missing and they landed
on dumpster and generally okay this is
what happened I mean dungeon the Dragons
have been around for a while but it was
a pretty it was very full yeah it was a
pretty cold thing it's Underground yeah
it was kind of an underground game a lot
of kids playing real nerdy real and so
it didn't really you know make any kind
of inroads into the mainstream until
later and there was a there was a kid
James Dallas Egbert the third yeah and
he was he was like a child prodigy yeah
I was in college at 15 yeah at 15 or 16
I'm sure nerd yeah it was yeah and he
went missing
yeah from his dorm yeah and they when
they were looking in his dorm room and
trying to find out where he might have
gone
most parents hired well it's that sort
of fee I to find right first so in his
dorm room there was like a cork board
and there were these push pins in it and
the shape that the pushpins were in and
I don't even know why the guy yeah he
was pretty brilliant
actually I guess on the shape of the
pushpins and he said that looks like the
underground the layout of the
underground tunnels or the steam Tom the
steam tunnels underneath the school
underneath the school so he figured
that's where the kid had gone yeah
because he played Dungeons and Dragons
and that was about dungeons and so they
thought that he went down inside the
steam cop tunnels to play this game
right which they knew nothing about
right and as it turned out now they
didn't find him though he was down there
he wasn't down there no um and actually
they didn't find him for a while did
they know they found about his friends
house yeah he actually he went to his
friend's house what had ended up
happening that they
find out later that he did go down to
the steamteam didn't go down there and
he took an overdose of quaaludes
the intention of committing suicide but
I didn't kill him
yeah so he goes to the friend's house
and hide that and hides out they were
able to find him and they put him up
wait a minute no they were able to find
him and then he moved to Louisiana right
where he got a job working in the oil
field and tried to kill himself again
well it was cyanide but he survived but
he survived that also survived that he
got was like he was like rats Putin and
I couldn't pull his poison eventually he
ended up killing himself with a
self-inflicted gunshot wound that was an
80 bro but it had nothing to do with
Dungeons & Dragons but the popular media
conception was that I mean just because
of that of those pushpins on the on the
thing that the investigator saw yeah it
looked like those Steve towels and like
I said the kid actually did go down to
the same towels but he was going down
there to kill himself I don't think
Dungeons and Dragons he just kind of he
was unstable right you had a lot of drug
problem but in the media for some reason
that that really caught the media's
attention even based a movie off of it
well run a Jaffe a book called mazes and
monsters and they made a movie based of
them with a very young Tom Hanks was in
it so it was kind of from that point on
that the whole you know the whole
relationship between Dungeons and
Dragons and luring children into
Satanism and suicide and stuff like that
that's kind of where that came from
because with all these like kind of
fundamentalists in their pulpits they're
telling all these all of their
parishioners that you know this game is
teaching your children how to cast
spells magic selling their soul to the
devil killing their parents yeah because
what would happen is every now and then
you have a psycho killers parents and
then when they're getting he said well
Dungeons and Dragons maybe do it
oh yeah because that's what you heard on
television yeah maybe he did play
Dungeons & Dragons but I had nothing to
do with the murders of right and really
and I was gonna say to you that's why is
this kind of thing it actually kind of
ends up eating itself in the end and
actually it it makes its own momentum
because even if Dungeons & Dragons
didn't have anything to do with the
first ones by the time it gets into the
media then people are committing crimes
and blaming it on that yeah even if it
didn't have anything to do so then that
just keeps fueling and fueling it is
just like snowballs and I think that's
kind of what ended up happening right in
this case but so yeah it's kind of sad
now but to think about now yeah because
Dungeons & Dragons just seems so
innocent yeah is this a dirty game yeah
it's just a dirty game rolling dice you
have your imagination
oh and oh about the church what the
church did not want people using their
imagination no that was very dangerous
well yeah obviously I was gonna say to
you we we actually we watched a lot of
the old VHS videos there's a lot of them
on YouTube if you look up there's I
think there's a channel called a cult
hilarity yeah it has a bunch of ones on
there there was one where there was
these two preachy douchebags like
talking to each other and one had a
really pretty common oh yeah it was it
was it was it was on it was it was a
Freddie Mercury
it was a nice Ken hair I'm sure he ended
up in some kind of scandal involved yeah
but these people actually they had like
a whole table full of toys that they I'm
sure they played with after the camera
was off some of the toys quite awesome
and this guy basically like not not the
not the [ __ ] second mouth guy but the
other guy basically said that he
believed the rumor that if you took the
pieces from Dungeons & Dragons like the
little minute miniature figures that
some people used to plan and threw them
into a fire into the incinerator that
they would scream that you'd hear
screams because obviously what happens
when you throw a Ouija board into fire
screams and in Green Smoke
well that's true that's what they say
that's true I've seen it happen now I
really haven't seen that but and also
the funniest thing too about this
particular video that we were watching
and all their awesome toys that they
said et was gay yeah and I missed that
connection
what was the connection either he could
levitate like gay guys can and they were
saying that he was some kind of
substitute Jesus because he came down
from heaven and he could he could
levitate children something like that it
was really bad but how did they get gay
I don't know I wasn't I wasn't really
paying close attention I wasn't either
but it's like well it just seemed like
it just kind of went further it was
blurring the the [ __ ] just kind of
bird yeah every time we were so busy we
were so busy laughing at what they said
yeah keep up with it but well the funny
thing too were they talking about they
were talking about he-man and and they
said well he man is satanic because He
Man is mastering the universe and only
God is the master universe so and also
they said some [ __ ] about
skeletor's staff with the RAM head on it
or whatever oh and also my favorite
thing too about that was that they said
the Smurfs were satanic yeah yeah and
then black lips and they don't have lips
at all right well because they said oh
they said they were satanic because
they're like dead people because their
skin is blue and their lips are black
and I'm like are you high it's like they
don't have black lips and they said that
that little girl Smurf was a transsexual
yeah I don't remember that episode no I
don't know that either did she turn into
a boy they said she was a boy that
turned into a girl but I don't remember
that I don't really I don't really I
didn't really watch that like I saw some
of it I'm just you know and those names
were bet Smurfette yeah I know I did
think when I was younger that she was
probably like the victim of a lot of
gang thanks
she was the only girl you know she was
the only chick around I don't think
smart said sexy just to buy mushrooms
okay well we wanted to talk about the
police training video yeah lay this one
out this one was really okay so
somewhere and this is on YouTube too if
you guys wanna watch it and it's called
the law enforcement guide to satanic
cults and this thing is hilarious oh
it's there it came out in 1994 we were
amazed that and I thought look look I
graduate from high school in 1990 I was
come out of the army at that and you
were coming down the Army Network and I
had thought it all kind of blown over by
that point evidently not unless these
the [ __ ] that made this video and
they were trying to sell it to police
and no one bought it I don't know yeah I
don't know if anyone ever bought that
can't see how the police would have
bought that training video because a guy
that doesn't that that doesn't teach a
cop anything it doesn't seem
particularly helpful
no and now the the guy that made it it
was the old ball guy named Gordon
Coulter who they have listed as top
slash pastor and and then there's this
other guy who had the most magical
mullet yeah oh so good imagine okay him
you know you know uh David Bowie from
the Ziggy Stardust face he had that red
or that orange is mullet yeah imagine
you magnified that twice it was really
tall and really long and then you took
that that mullet and put it off possum
that's what this looks like dude looks
like a possum you'll see we're put a
picture of him oh yeah if I hope I can
find but he's hilarious he's supposed to
be an ex satanic priest right and to
prove it he shows a picture of himself
in a priest outfit standing beside a
table full of a cult where they call a
cultic better make a cult of cultic
making words hair if an occult
paraphernalia that looks like he bought
it at the local spiritual shop
and that was his proof of being a
satanic priest and it's it's the whole
it's just hilarious he got he they do it
opens up with a demonstration of him
walking through a park finding cult
symbols on trees and on the ground and
as he walks through the park they cut to
an overhead map they're not kind of
artificially generated map yeah like a
little art yeah that doesn't look real
at all and every time he gets to a
location it's supposed to be pointing it
on the map somehow but it doesn't tell
you you have to see it to believe it you
can't tell where on that map they're
supposed to be pointing tell me why it
matters well the awesome thing I think
what he was trying to do was say this I
don't remember what Park it was but he
said okay well this is what law
enforcement should be looking out for
where if you go into a park and this is
how you know that Satanists or occultus
or whatever have been in here doing
rituals all right and so like he was
showing now we cut off yes come into the
park and here's a tree and it has a
pentagram drawn on it in chalk and you
know that's this is like the entrance to
the to the ritual area or whatever and
the most hilarious thing is that when he
goes over there's like there's a tree
with a pentagram on it which is right
set up it's not even like a satanic
upside down he points that but she does
point that up but then there's another
tree with all that upside down cross and
he's like touching the chalk and he's
like oh it's pretty fresh and I'm like
douchebag you drew that yeah you do that
over the video for the video yeah it's
just funny they couldn't find any I
should know
Nate remember he finds the noose he
finds it this could have been used in an
animal sacrifice or a human sack look
there's blood on it under his blood on
he's touching his hands and I didn't am
eating evidence no it was just hilarious
well and the funny thing too is that the
implication being it's like look if
people are gonna go into a park and do
some little pagan ritual or something
and they're not sacrifice animals right
they're not doing anything illegal oh
you don't do remember he said that he
said homosexuals come out here to the
park yeah until that [ __ ] said he's
like equating Satanists with
homosexuality
yeah for that
well because remember like evil minutes
before he said that when he was like
Satan this Satan that I was like homos
what he's gonna bring up the homos yeah
yeah and they're a couple minutes later
he's like homosexuality - I'm like okay
yeah fundamentalist bingo and so yeah so
there was that douchebag and then he
also had a segment where he showed
different types of altars like this is a
satanic altar and this is a voodoo altar
this is a like a Wiccan and then they
list off all the different ceremonies
and on what or what date they happen
yeah and he listed so many of them
basically there's some occult ritual
happening on every [ __ ] much every
[ __ ] day so yeah they're trying to
make like cops and so any crime anywhere
is satanic just yes pretty much yeah
there he lists off all all the pom all
of the attributes of a satanic crime and
when he lifts them all off this it's
like well that's any crime it was every
crime you could imagine could be put
into these the best thing about that
ritualistic the best thing about that
list was that it was not it was not um
because if it was me I would have put it
in like order of severity but he didn't
really do that it's like it's kind of
like you know child sacrifice that it
was like vandalism yeah
what about orgies the orgies including
vaginal oral and anal sex yeah yeah and
it was the anal always oral and anal
vaginal that's every time they said orgy
boy it was vaginal oral anal activity
activities that's a recall and I said
hey dibs on the band name the anal
activities I had a former band called
the anal activities or just first album
coming out soon and he's like well don't
orgies include all that anyway that's
what I mean it's like
we're gonna have a vaginal ollie a
nothing
vaginas yeah what else was in that
training video else that you remember
them that was kind of really hokey again
it's on YouTube just like it's called
it's called law enforcement guide to
satanic Ultramax I can't imagine all
things on YouTube can't imagine any any
police force buying that but if they did
you know what I forgot that now okay now
this is kind of terrible so this is kind
of like a sensitive subject but on the
training video before we get off that
they had a list of like symptoms of how
you could tell if your child had been
ritually so it's had never I know what
you get that you know and like you know
yes child abuse is awful okay
and but some of the well one a lot of it
was like really generic it was just kind
of like any kids yeah you know it's like
oh the kid is got syphilis gonorrhea
of course yeah it should be a red flag
right there and our favorite is blood or
semen in his pants yeah well yeah I
would think so yeah just ridiculous also
if you touch his boobie and his
sphincter relaxes that was another one
I can't believe they actually said that
but as it was for law enforcement use
but it was there is something about that
particular video that makes me think
that it was basically Church propaganda
that they made a video just telling
people that it was for law enforcement
but we're gonna show it to you guys
secretly and they actually never
intended to sell it so long for I buy
that maybe it was just made to look like
in the law enforcement video and they
were showing it to parishes Commission
because honestly I was kind of thinking
when we were watching it I was like this
is not going to be any help to any law
enforcement agency anywhere no because
one all the [ __ ] about crimes they're a
knowledge it right the only thing and
then it was like a cult was about like
the symbols and the and the altars and
I'm like well if a crime has been
committed
does that [ __ ] really matter no it
wouldn't matter only the crime would
matter right and the forensic evidence
on what is it really was really all they
ever say anything with you could
describe all these weird [ __ ] that you'd
find in a crime scene as if you find
this get help wait a minute cops yeah
the church is what they're saying right
so open I boot I think what it was I
think it might've been a fake law
enforcement training video that they
show people in churches saying that
we're gonna give you some secret cop
training this is what the cops I buy
that that's probably what it was yeah I
can say that I think that would be more
like what I can do because I don't think
the cops would need any of that
yeah and you that so-called training as
they should I mean nothing in there
would would have been hell no none of
that nothing it was either redundant
information or a useless impervious I'm
not sure it was real no but but like I
said it's on YouTube it's very funny if
you want to watch it and you know feel
your sphincter relaxed
so we also kind of wanted to talk about
others like so much this is such a rich
vein yeah there's a we just so we have
like we have like three pages of notes
where I just like wrote down phrases and
all the [ __ ] because it's impossible to
cover this history yeah I just had to
kind of live through it to understand it
yeah what we might do I think I kind of
wanted to talk about did it maybe we'll
talk about the Geraldo show for a couple
minutes and then we'll take a break and
then I'll come back and tell you about
like some of the other Aldo was like you
took PT Barnum and the ultimate [ __ ]
show and mashed it together and threw in
Ozzy Osbourne right and and Ozzy
Osbourne was like the coolest part of
the whole thing poor guy I thought I did
that about anyway I don't want to ruin
it now
Oh Geraldo now he's still around oh yeah
yeah he is the biggest [ __ ] he's
reheat well he's apologized for the
douche barrel well yeah because they
asked him to because it was really
irresponsible I mean he wasn't the only
one he wasn't the only one like Sally
Jessy Raphael did one or two shows on it
Oprah did one for all I know Ricky like
did but I don't fry I think for a while
maybe refueling Ricki Lake mostly just
did paternity tests baby mama and baby
daddies yeah yeah yeah
but yeah the the most famous one was her
Aldo and that was from 1988 yeah and
what was the title of it exposing
Satan's underground yeah inflection well
it was a two-hour special yeah I was a
two-hour special and at the time
everybody saw it at the time it was the
most-watched documentary yeah yeah I
don't know what it was on TV it was on
NBC oh I remember it I remember when it
went down yeah I remember stated it was
almost like Al Capone's vault memory was
gonna open up Al Capone's vault
live yeah and they found a glass bottle
yeah we should yeah I'm glad the skin
that's broke his nose today by his
skinheads well he weren't skinheads or
neo-nazi kids yeah what would share
honor busted his nose and he wore that
and John his nose for months trying to
go up that yeah I made his career but so
this show this show is also available on
YouTube we just watched it last night
and from 1988 and this is just the
saddest most sensationalistic obviously
manufactured outrage you have ever seen
yeah and it's just whenever anyone trust
started to make sense
Geraldo had to change the subject yes we
talked to this lunatic oh that's better
tan and lay it out for us lay it out for
three yeah well you know I was gonna say
what in relation to that one of the best
things about it was remember the one
time and it was it was right there were
no commercials in it boo it was right
before he was gonna go to commercial
right before he'd come back from
commercial and he was saying something
along the lines of you know I know that
you know people will do these shows and
like we want our kids to watch it
because well I don't even remember what
he was heavy they had these dire
warnings don't let your kids watch this
we're serious yeah you know and then he
goes on later we know that when we do
these disclaimers it causes more people
to watch it okay but we're serious yeah
don't watch this don't let your kids
watch this and it was just like them
like my irony meter Explorer yeah he was
awesome
I need another iron meter again you
gotta hand it to her although though
that's sexy [ __ ] could spin some
[ __ ] boy he he could hike with his big
old porn stache and he's sitting there
looking all yeah and he interviewed was
like ron jeremy super ego ron jeremy oh
that damn hold on look it's probably
almost time to hear from our sponsors
actually okay so what we're gonna do is
we are going to take a short break and
then we will be back and we're gonna
talk more about this stuff and yeah
before we get deep into it before we
yeah before we get too far into it we
get carried away and I'll forget all
about it
okay so we'll be back in just a few
minutes
I would like to take a second and thank
subculture corsets in clothing for
sponsoring project I radio and my show
while listening to my podcast please
take a second and visit their website at
www.att.com/biz
Rabelais gothic steampunk and pinup
clothing shoes and accessories again
their website is subculture corsets comm
or if you're in the Jacksonville Florida
area stop by their store in The Avenues
Mall and if you like to save money use
the discount code 13 o'clock when
checking out and save 10% off your
entire order by the way if you're a
curvy girl subculture do not forget
about you they carry size 4 to 4 X and
guys they have men's clothing and shoes
as well so go shop at subculture corsets
calm now and use the discount code 13
o'clock for a 10% discount
okay satanic panic we're back we're
talking about the Geraldo show yes yes
lay it out first Jenni lay it out okay
well like the show was super unfocused
right but there was an ad detest I'll
show it was yeah a lot of creative well
because he didn't and he didn't let
anybody talk a minute or so it's almost
to my trial yeah a lot of them you know
a lot of daytime talk shows back then
did seem like that it seems like the
guests were kind of you're like in the
pillory and then like all the all the
audience members were like almost like
disapproving like they were judging you
know it was kind of like that Ozzie what
the figure in this case was found with a
tattoo of your name on his shoulder how
do you don't you feel responsible for
poor Aziz like I know who know that guy
I just write songs
soon as soon as I said I'm from a lower
middle-class background I had no real
prospect prospects in life and I became
an entertainer and I'm just want to put
on a good show and this is an OK Ozzie
we've heard enough from you ain't gone
to the next one yeah
synthesized you started making sense and
being you know you know as he's a nice
guy you know he's a little app you know
his brains a little fried addled and
he's allowed but he's a nice guy he was
used looking good then money he was yeah
that's really good that might have been
a wig though I think it was a way I kind
of feel like you sound like kind of a
judge yeah I thought sure it wasn't
Slimani telling it a little bit but I
did I felt bad form of the show because
it seemed like Geraldo which is like
grilling him and he didn't really know
what to yeah he's like what are you yeah
why what are you Hughes in you yeah I'm
an entertainer yeah yeah and he's an
obvious professional entertainer and as
soon as he soon as he made sense and as
soon as he sees as soon as he seems like
a sympathetic character oh we got to get
rid of Ozzy yeah so instead let's
another guy that kind of got now the
most well-spoken person on that show was
the guy from the temple obsessed yeah I
can't turn old something brother he was
actually the colonel in the Army right
Carl yeah he looked just like I thought
he might he look just like Spock he had
the eyebrows walking he was working it
yeah he was a smart guy he was the only
one that seemed lucid yeah honestly out
of all the people in Anton LaVey his
daughter Gina loved a just she was just
you know going like what the hell's
going on here yeah she actually I kind
of felt bad for her too because she
seemed like she did had no idea like
what to say and she didn't you know she
came up with one good thing she's like
where are the bodies yeah you know all
these people are being killed where are
the bodies because here's the thing
about the show and this is what pissed
me off about it the most and it's funny
but the repercussions of it were not
really so funny like the repercussions
at that whole outburst of moral panic
was that
Geraldo was one making a
sensationalistic show that people would
watch under the auspices of saying that
he was helping because oh there's this
huge organized network of Satanists and
they're kidnapping children they're
using women as brood mares they're you
know there's this systematic ya know
they can typically and the safe
infiltrates but no one's investigating
you know we're helping right now he was
helping fuel the panic that's exactly
what he was doing and him and everyone
that did a show like that in that days
it's like I kind of hold them
responsible for encouraging that
[ __ ] you're making money off of it
just like they made money off of the
anko ancient witch witch trials witch
hunters made money and yeah and lenders
opened up for the witch burnings and you
know people sold food during witch
burnings yeah you know that's that's
it's it's just a modern and that's a
danger that's really the shittiest
things because you think of this day and
age yeah you would think that people
would be but here's the thing it's like
we seem like we're much more
technologically sophisticated you gotta
gather but I mean scratch the surface of
that and we're no better yeah the day
the difference was is that that was
pre-internet
if have the internet existed in those
days people would have called [ __ ]
yeah I don't think you can because
because the doubters would have had a
voice hey where are the bodies where is
the physical evidence it's you know I
mean where else it's nothing has ever
been found never nope well if you if you
look at the testimony of the supposed
victims the little kids they were
claiming to be flushed down a toilet
alive and would appear in underground
sacrificial rooms where they were
molested on mass by groups of weirdos
including chuck norris cleaned up and
returned to the day care center
you know squeaky clean so the parents
wouldn't notice right bless you kid down
the toilet may arrive safe that's
awesome and has an encounter and hasn't
encountered with that song Nora that's
the Harry Potter [ __ ] right there yes it
was boating movie [ __ ] fly they were
saying that people could fly there is
yeah you're kind of yeah this is about
that's the next thing I want to talk
about because here's what I was leading
to from the Geraldo show is that because
of that or because of that whole
hysteria of thinking that there were
these you know on these underground
networks of Satanists no they're kind of
came a thing where there were people
running day care centers that were one
recruiting kids or molesting kids or
sacrificing kids or whatever and it was
like a whole organized network at home
yeah and and they could be traced up to
the Illuminati so that's kind of telling
yeah member the illumina Eltham Utley
the Illuminati was in charge of this
yeah or at least some sets well yeah yes
they said they didn't filtrate it all
levels of government and there was all
this [ __ ] going on and like I said you
know it's easy to laugh about it now
nothing was ever found no yes
children get molested yes there are
weirdos out there that do stupid weird
ritualistic psycho crimes yes that does
happen yeah but this copycat crap right
it's and and honestly I think the more
that that kind of God in the media and
guy I think there was more of it because
people are like oh that's
good idea I'm gonna I'm gonna commit
this crime that I would have committed
anyway yeah and then they catch a serial
killing over the devil made me do it
yeah like [ __ ] Richard Ramirez doing
the pentagram on his hands yeah
ac/dc made me do it
right I'm The Night Stalker yeah even
though he was just like a [ __ ] nut
hello there yeah and the same thing
happened with and there and actually
look up this kid Sean Sellars Sen and he
he was a media darling back in the
eighties wasn't he he was actually 16 or
17 he shot a convenience store clerk
just for the hell of it no he wasn't
selling beer because he wouldn't sell
America that's right and which that's
for the hell of it oh yeah
although later he said it was because I
was trying to break all the Ten
Commandment yeah ok but I think he
didn't say that so no of course not he
was just Wow
and then later he killed his parents
right yeah both his parents my or maybe
it was just his mom I thought he killed
both babies 3 yeah ok so anyways right
yeah so anyway he got arrested and I
think he was 17 when he went to prison
yeah I got the death penalty and he got
the death penalty now he claimed later
that he had been a Satanist
yeah and he went on the kind of media
circuit and he was in like a bunch of
church recruiting videos you know on the
Geraldo shows on the Geraldo show you
used this boy up so did the preachers
yeah the preachers just used him up it
was awesome they used him as an example
they said now now kid tell all these
parents like what they should look for
Roger kid and like how the kids getting
into Satanism but this kid was obviously
pulling [ __ ] out of his ass oh yeah and
just making all this crap up
and the real Satanists on there like the
Vaes daughter and the guys from the
template set you know that they kind of
were like wait who's this guy yeah yeah
religious Satanism because I mean the
religion of Satanism doesn't have
anything David yeah you might want to
tell him a little bit about what Anton
LaVey Satanic Bible was well I mean
honestly that was more just kind of it
was more like Friedrich Nietzsche yes
like an agnostic libertarian it was a
form of atheism yeah
no not stylized atheism it yeah really
and actually I mean the Church of Satan
now it just seems like it's kind of like
atheists that like to troll Christians
yeah for red dress up and dress up yeah
which you know whatever well if you look
at the pro if you look at Anton LaVey
and some of the prototype Satanist you
really just say yeah those were gods
prototype Goths yeah [ __ ] with
[ __ ] with people yeah
dressed nothing black clothes I've never
had anything to do with sacrifice on
anybody or anything no sacrifices or
religious is a Christian concept they
didn't sacrifice they don't believe in
killing people or hurting children they
were believed that animals shouldn't be
sacrificed that they have rights you
know and that humans were just another
form of an animal they were Hamill's but
that animals you know were awesome if
you were awesome but you know you can
read it yourself
yeah so the sad thing so what ended up
happening was Sean Sellars after he got
pimped around by all these preachers
yeah and everything he did get executed
yeah he was 29 yeah he was actually at
the time I didn't mate and maybe maybe
he wasn't the youngest person to get the
death but well he didn't get the death
penalty was 29 but it was for a crime he
can do before and he was right probably
wouldn't cry wouldn't fly today no but
in those days in the state that he was
in yeah I think was Texas when it
Oklahoma oh girl this is that so and and
I should say later that even after he
died said his family thought he was full
of [ __ ] yeah and they saw his conversion
to Christianity was [ __ ] yes well so
did all the the other inmates and the
other and
prison wardens just said that no that
dude didn't convert to Christianity and
he's just [ __ ] he was just trying to
get out just trying to get out early
he's trying to get I'm trying to get his
sentence commuted probably and all that
Satanism but dungeons dragons [ __ ] yeah
that's right blank Dungeons and Dragons
- did he that's yeah I think it was his
main thing though that was basically
just he was absolving himself up
responsibility is what he was doing I'm
sure he was trying to say oh it wasn't
me it was I got into Satanism like and
Dungeons & Dragons made me do it
he was trying to play the Jesus Jesus
card and get his sentence commuted their
life didn't work no he's dead I saw
through it yeah yeah everybody did okay
I don't think there was that many people
now actually thought it was genuine no
but
so speaking of crimes and also [ __ ] like
that I wanted to get into the minutes
with the horizon with overall the show
yeah pretty much
okay we wanted to get into the McMartin
preschool thing because yeah oh man cuz
this this makes me so mad I got I gotta
take the truth when I first heard this
case in those days I thought that maybe
there was something to it because they
had people arrested well we're trying
and what something must and going back
to the Geraldo shown of the Geraldo show
had a bunch of the McMartin parents yeah
it's member there was like a driver
kaboom was there that's right which leg
it lent credence to this that's what I
mean is why I hold them responsible Ross
kind of crap because this this happened
a lot this was only the most famous case
but there was a lot of this going on
yeah I'm a smaller on a smaller scale
but this was like the biggest one at the
time and basically it was a it was a
preschool in California it was owned by
a family the McMartin family they were
some other employees friends of the
family that worked there daycare no
complaints never anything like that now
one of the mothers of the children I
think made the initial allegations
saying that her kid was had been
molested now I read somewhere that
actually her ex-husband her estranged
husband often worked at
huh so she might have had some kind of
ulterior motives
right to now like I said here's the
shitty thing about it is that yes
children really do get molested
yes horrible things like that happened
so it's almost like when something like
this happens it's almost like you want
to disbelieve like every every case
every case of it and you can't do that
and that's that's why I don't like this
kind of [ __ ] like muddying the waters
right because because this [ __ ] okay
this just got ludicrous like the woman
made the initial allegations saying that
kid was molested and as it went on it
just kind of snowballed into this
ridiculous I mean there's no way that
this [ __ ] could have been out no way for
this matter
there's no way that she could have been
having now several of the the owners of
the day carrots they're only employees
were arrested yeah and they you know
they questioned a bunch of the kids and
a bunch of the kids parents some of the
[ __ ] the kids were coming up with was
hilarious was just yeah scary but
hilarious that was just no way could
that have happened these kids lyin yeah
these kids said they saw witches flying
around they were in a hot-air balloon
that could be flushed down a toilet
flushed down it arrived in a secret
chamber that there were tunnels
underneath the daycare that went to
remote sites where they would be used in
what porn flicks and rituals there were
orgies at car washes and Airport yeah
and a dude spent five years the owner
spent five years in prison behind all
these accusations yeah and they couldn't
even find these tunnels no nothing there
yes these kids said that they showed
they I mean they showed the kids
pictures of like people that molested
them except one of the kids picked up
Chuck Norris yeah some of the kids said
they'd had holes drilled through them
it was just [ __ ] and it's like
nobody nobody believes that if you got
raped by Chuck Norris you would be
walking
so okay so this trial went on and at the
time it was the longest and most
expensive criminal trial in US history
yeah went on for years and years and
years it was like the Nuremberg trials
it was a minute it just went on and on
it went on for what [ __ ] it was still it
didn't end five six years it didn't go
it didn't end till 1990 yeah so five six
years didn't end till 1990 now during
the course of the trial and somewhat
afterward now a you know spoiler alert
at the end of the trial
no one was convicted no one they could
find nothing there was no evidence if
any of these kids have been molested
there was no evidence of any tunnels
Chuck Norris didn't hurt anybody
there was no no witches were flying
around you know kids were flushed down
the toilet
no animals were harmed in the making at
this pond and they find out that the
prosecution held back all this evidence
that the woman who brings up the
accusations was [ __ ] crazy was
mentally it was mentally ill and an
alcoholic and now go and then what else
did they hold back on there was just all
kinds of stuff all the exculpatory
evidence that would have freed the
accused they held it back yeah and it
was because the prosecutor was coming up
for re-election and he was on the losing
side of her reelection yeah which man
that goes the chimney was like oh man of
a whole like cult of child molesters I'm
nice and I'm gonna be elected forever
yeah I'm a hero which goes to show you
you cannot rely on that system
you got good people in that system but
they got people that are out for their
own and also here's another thing too
and I kind of wanted to go into this
briefly there was a book that came out
and this was this kind of fueled into a
lot of it as well a book came out in
1980 and it was called Michelle
remembers written by Michelle Smith and
Lawrence pastor who was her therapist
and actually they married later yeah so
you know take of that that what she well
so basically that was what started the
whole quote/unquote recover
memory movement saying that in this book
she claimed that under hypnosis she had
remembered that her parents had
basically pimped her out to a satanic
cult who did all these horrible things
to her and she didn't remember it until
later on which nowadays most people know
that that's crap
you know usually if something traumatic
happens to you you don't forget it and
also under hypnosis people can become
actually very suggestible so you can
plant anything you want and make it seem
like a memory later on so you know
there's whole gray area but it was a
very long one only says in the
weak-minded though okay only in the weak
mind
well if nobody wants is it not the
droids you're looking for all right
so well you know that's that's good all
right so so basically the two of them
these two [ __ ] that wrote this book
they were either friends with or they
consulted with the parents and the
children and sat in on some of the
questioning and whatnot for this
McMartin preschool trial so they
basically determined that these idiots
were coaching the children yeah and
actually one of the kids later on when
they grew up
yeah they came out they came out and
said yeah we just made it or ended up
because they would accept anything they
said they wouldn't accept any other
answer they just kept if we answered
something they didn't want then they we
just asked it again we just kept making
[ __ ] up until we got something they said
okay that's what okay yeah because you
know they just did what their parents
wanted them to do and you know like I
said there was this whole recovery
memory thing too and that kind of fall
factored into it and like I said at the
end of it these poor people that Ray
Buckey the the main guy don't know if he
was the owner he was like someone that
worked that he was the aren't he might
have been the are okay I think he was in
prison for five years yeah and he didn't
do oh god I never got charged they
couldn't find they didn't charge anybody
zero convictions zero convictions and
that like I said that just
to show like this kind of [ __ ] it's so
silly and so stupid like you have all
these stupid fundamentalist people
standing and they're in their churches
saying he-man is Satan and this is
satanic and not satanic but it actually
does affect real people's lolly got
people in these churches saying well of
course he did it there's a devil there's
a devil then that means you did it yeah
that's what they sang and that's kind of
going back to like on the Geraldo shows
the same it's the same logic that was in
the Salem witch trials that's what I
mean when they going phantasmal evidence
yeah that it was based on phantasmal
evidence yeah where was it go phantasm
11 spiritual evidence spirit yeah that's
exactly the same spiritual evidence is
the evidence you just feel that exists
yeah I feel that it exists so therefore
it exists yeah it's spiritual I know
it's spiritually I pulled it yeah it's
just like I said it's so sad and and
actually if you guys have not read it
there's a good book by Michael Shermer
called why people believe weird things
and he does a whole chapter about I
think he talks about the McMartin
preschool try a little bit in there but
he talks about the satanic panic and
compares it directly to the Salem boys
Charlotte and he shows like the pattern
of what happened was pretty much exactly
the same
it was the same [ __ ] and gods got caught
up in it we did heavy metal guys yeah
and that yeah I was gonna mention that
as well because your your your mom or
dad or run into your room at any moment
start tearing up your albums you didn't
you never knew what I knew a lot of kids
at have yeah yeah I had built tear up
some [ __ ] every now and then no way did
you know I didn't the Judas Priest
poster man tore it up oh yeah it wasn't
anything to his satan though he's good
that guy's a [ __ ] KK downing alone
Whitney robbed her
you got the wrong gig and he wasn't even
out then I guess they'll call it the
worst thing happened to me it's like my
grandpa was kind of curmudgeon and he
was all his big thing was cuz I was
rolling to like kind of goth and new
waves and stuff like that so you know oh
they're all gay they're wrong the
earrings what's it boy spandex makeup
girlfriend does his hair they were right
that was also his girlfriend so we also
want to talk about oh we want to talk
about that one case just kind of briefly
with the Clifford st. Joseph who was guy
was that that was the guy with the gay
hooker Oh him yeah yeah bad [ __ ]
now in and here's another case of one
there's like a lone horrible person he
might have had some help you might have
had one guy with it yeah but that kind
of gets tied into so it's like oh well
here's this crazy person so that's
indicative of like a much larger trend
which is not always the case but that's
kind of what happened in this guy's case
he was kind of a Jeffrey Dahmer yeah
it's just a serial killer yeah a sadist
yeah sexual sadist picking up these
young crackhead type yeah male per guys
and taking it back to the house take him
back to his house town I like keeping
him captive keeping them torture them
over a period of time and evidently he
may have had help maybe one other guy
tell me find a like a skull like in his
wall or yeah yeah he just had body parts
in certain places and one guy got away
that's her man to the cops yeah they're
gonna sacrifice him because everything
he'd to have more than one guy at a time
and was groom and some of them for
evidently sacrifice not only thing it
might have been a real
sacrifice let me show that killed the
guy but I think the guy was just
role-playing being some kind of a wizard
Saint Satanic wizard or something either
that or it was just a way of justifying
what he was doing he's just a lunatic
really you can't take the actions of
just one batshit crazy person right that
was not part of a seat and say it's part
of some big organizer snow like oh you
know it's like it's kind of like he
would throw this [ __ ] with the
freemasons that kind of [ __ ] it's like
you take these little bitty I mean yeah
that guy was a serial killer yeah he was
crazy he killed a bunch of people and
that's terrible yeah but that's not
indicative of a larger trend and doesn't
mean that there's those people that do
that they may have been playing off of a
larger trend because they had the
satanic panic what's going on who's
going on and so he's like oh man would
you look at pictures of the guys just a
middle-aged loser
yeah middle-aged loser nobody yeah
that's who he was and that's another
thing too is that a lot of these guys
that commit these sorts of crimes are
exactly that kind of yeah what he was
scary-looking
yeah they're just kind of these schlubby
slow me middle-aged white dudes yeah and
I think that even if they're not really
Satanists or they don't really they
think that's [ __ ] they'll kind of
latch on to that they want to be a saint
because yeah it'll give them more
attention right they'll feel more
powerful you know they'll you know
they'll get in the media so satanic
killer and now suddenly he's somebody he
may have even bought the Satanic Bible
Anton LaVey his book and ready go [ __ ]
that Vista much trouble crazy yeah it
really was and you know like I said a
lot of it was funny you know especially
all the [ __ ] about I'm still laughing
about the [ __ ] firm the deficit
dragons pieces in the center yeah
screaming coming out just ridiculous how
the Smurfs were saying yeah just fantasy
well kept people going to church yeah I
think part of it was is that you had you
know
this society was becoming rapidly more
secular yeah so the fundamentalists were
being threatened their way man we're
losing members we have to have a panic
to bring them all back right so think
that was part of I think that generally
happens there's a lot of groups like
especially when they feel like they're
losing their grip or they feel like
they're losing their power in society
well the money was drying up so they
hadn't don't get more extreme because
for people that didn't live through that
time you had a lot of televangelists and
the televangelists were all getting
defrocked as basically showmen you know
it was like something out of Hollywood
yeah you know they did get it they'd
have their own little show was almost
kind like a reality show they get up
there and preach and they try to be
something that they weren't and then
thought they'd get busted by the cops
with male prostitutes or they'd get
busted having an affair with some kind
of hustler honey and the the
televangelists was on the decline you
know they were there because every
single one of them was a fake got yeah
if you were bidding for something if you
were big you were a fake now I'm sure
they had good preachers but they were
probably mid-level or lower level they
were local all the ones on TV were the L
wasn't the TV were Charlotte they were
told yeah I know it was helping total
hypocrites and that was actually
destroying Christianity yeah you know
even Depeche Mode was writing songs
about it from that time yeah Jesus and
all that that's right
and like he said it it seemed like that
was why I was so surprised that lon for
that quote unquote law enforcement video
come out so late like in 94 because to
me it seemed like by the time I
graduated high school you didn't really
hear about it much anymore now when I
was in high school in the late 80s I did
have a book I didn't pay for it
someone stole it and then they gave it
to me
by Bob Larson who I think is still
around okay he's he's an evangelist and
an exorcist
yeah also he has a couple hot daughters
and their exorcist salsa so if you ever
want to be exorcised by kind
a hot crazy chick yeah sure I think they
still do it yeah but yeah his name's Bob
Larson I'm not sure if he's still alive
if he is he's probably like 150 years
old but he wrote this book that somebody
stole because they thought it would be
funny and then they gave it to me and it
was called Satanism something it had
like a subtitle and I remember reading
that book over and over just laughing my
[ __ ] ass off because he had a he had
a chapter on Deficit dragons obviously
he had a chapter on heavy metal music
and even like some pretty like normal
music like rolling stones and stuff like
that somehow that was satanic to I don't
even remember if it wasn't part of the
church then it was satanic yeah if you
liked it it was satanic and and then he
had like this great chapter of like all
these satanic symbols and I always used
to laugh because one of the symbols it
was and there was a peace symbol yeah
and then Anarchy sign and an anarchy
they didn't really get punk-rock they
don't know what punk rock well I'm not
shocked yeah yeah they just sit Vicious
up there you know as an occult icon
you're going I don't think I've ever
heard him referred to as it it's just
it's so hard for you because I was not
raised particularly religious that my
family was not very religious and I
didn't really know and the weird thing
now is it seems like there's like all
these Christian schools and so I didn't
really know anybody in school that was
real religious like it wasn't something
that got talked about really it's like
everyone just kind of didn't talk about
I think in most areas this wasn't the
reality of everyday life and that was
being delivered us to us through the
media yeah there was times when I
thought maybe something like that was
happening but then as I got a little bit
older and more into the type of music
that they were talking about you know
Iron Maiden Judas Priest and metal and
then early goth you go nice people go
what the [ __ ] they're talking about know
they don't know what they don't they
don't have a single clue what they're
talking about and they just became
clownish yes ridiculous
and it was an attempt to get more people
into the churches yeah and it eventually
backfired maybe it worked for a little
while
well it I think it didn't work Wow but
see that's another thing that I can't
understand it's like I said because I
was raised you know not very religious
and I you know I lost and it was just
not something that held any interest for
me and I don't like so it's really hard
for me to wrap my head around these
people like this those dorks we saw in
the in the in the video with the with
the Smurf toys like dying about that
it's like I can't wrap my mind around
somebody that can live their whole life
that fearful yeah that ignorant oh they
were seeing the 666 symbol inside the
little logo for the Proctor for Proctor
my van oh that's right they eventually
know their logo just they were sick of
people bitching about it yeah it was
ridiculous it was just like it was a
cute little and this in the backward
masking in the records yeah you know
which their whole there were whole VHS
shows about backward men and I think
that might have been Bob Larson he kind
of had his fingers in a lot of pies well
you had to make money yeah so yeah yeah
with that new show he's um he's doing
exorcism so I think lost that very glass
I heard Kevin is traveling sighs I'm
pretty much well I think we covered most
of the most of the [ __ ] that I wrote
down oh damn I forgot to mention this
what's it and I need to go back and
mention this because it was funny as
hell
okay remember a couple minutes ago you
guys like you can back it up you know
remember what I was just talking about
that book Michelle remembers right yeah
about the recovered memory center yeah
okay so one of the claims she made in
that book hmm I mean there were a lot of
crazy you know - she was people were
pooping on her and also today but one of
the claims she made was that the
Satanists had surgically implanted a
Satan tail and Satan's damn that'd be
kind of cool they have people that pay
for that today there are these bodies
that how could that be
do you think
look good with a pointed tail yeah I
think it'd be kind of hot yeah long if
you long get to have a little speed on
the bottom well yeah it's got a drag on
the ground yeah yeah I could hit you
with yeah and they blow up to inch horn
sticking on top of your head yeah anyway
no she said she said she had that now
here's the funny thing is that the
period that she said she had that done
well there were pictures of her in the
school yearbook they were picture of her
their parents to it she did not have
horn to her tail no of course not she's
a pathological liar
right right animal how did she explain
that the horns in the tail were not
there at the time she said see I would
love I'm going to save it okay they
eventually surgically remove them again
that they surgically removed them so you
know what I kind of feel like or did she
didn't think that far ahead when she
said I don't think she did and honestly
I'm kind of thinking that I'm trying to
get into her crazy person mindset yeah
she probably said oh well they're
invisible therapist yeah and here's the
thing people I mean it was so insane
that people could get away with saying
this [ __ ] and people be like oh the
preimage age you couldn't say that today
no if you said that [ __ ] this showed up
on YouTube people would go through your
history people that would know you man
would school with that [ __ ] she never
had a warrant a damn good start saying I
remember that one time she said she rode
in on a pink elephant and just beats to
[ __ ] like that
yeah you couldn't get away with these
lives but now cuz you can verify
everything yeah now you know that's
honestly yeah we were talking about this
earlier I said I don't think the same
kind of [ __ ] would fly no now it is no
no part part of the reason why the
satanic panic flew is because the lack
of information and the flow of
information was slow back then
sure you depended basically on
television yeah good not many people
went down to go buy books you know cuz
life was busy back then - yeah and you'd
hear about it through word-of-mouth and
usually the source of origin was
television yeah and if you like to meet
it was a type of way today you can get
on youtube and watch a video over and
over like if it like your favorite music
video yeah back in those days you might
see it once a week
yeah no what about you would never see a
Bauhaus video no I
I remember how my co MTV once yeah I
remember having to wait like you'd
listen to the radio and wait for like
four hours for a good song come on and
then you hit the cassette yeah yeah and
then you try to cut off the end with the
commercial and [ __ ] yeah yeah never
understand what it was like it was a
simpler time it was it was in some ways
it was better but I wouldn't go back
though no I know that there's kind of a
lot of nostalgia yeah about a lot of 80s
stuff which I can get like I still like
a lot of eighties music and you know
most of this [ __ ] I like is 82 but and I
like a lot of the movies from ladies but
something safe I mean some good [ __ ]
back then yeah but your taste wasn't as
well defined sure has you you didn't you
didn't have access to anything yeah like
now you can just you can you can access
everything instantly yeah even [ __ ] like
we remembered when we were kids were
like hey that's a Woolworths what was
that [ __ ] TV show we were talking
about the other day with the schmooze on
it oh and and you were thinking about
that and we looked at and of course it's
on YouTube and I was like holy [ __ ] I
forgot everything's on that everything's
own commercials yeah crazy that's just
that's insane well that's pretty much it
we need to wrap it up then is there
anything else yeah on the satanic I
think I think we kind of covered
everything Chuck Norris children's toys
yeah leaving in a balloon gonna leave
the daycare in a balloon ritually
sacrificed and of course nobody in the
whole neighborhood saw this blimp or
balloon come take the kids I wonder if
the hot-air balloon was red with horns I
don't know we've gotta stop alright
alright we can run out we got a show
okay well anyway I hope you enjoyed the
show if you liked the show um check us
out on Twitter
13 o'clock check us out on Facebook 13
o'clock and check out our YouTube
channel which is 13 o'clock podcast yeah
and that's pretty much it right yeah our
YouTube show
as visuals to it well obviously it's
enhance the experience yeah invite you
to just subscribe yes or you can
download it from Project Radio yeah get
it from our block or whatever yeah links
are probably all in the description
anyway yeah yeah so you know look around
you you guys know okay so we'll see you
again next week
you